I want you have a look at this question
I wonder how many of you recognizes what
years is stupid
take your feet yeah so um the question
is just solved the question is just
solved okay what we going to do in this
well the first thing you will recognize
this one a lot of question the first
most important information you're going
to draw on is your log laws right that's
the basic piece so when you have a look
for example the left hand side what log
Lord is that trigger in your life when
you're adding locks you multiply the
partners side right so this should be
log base 2 of what X plus 2 X plus 3
which of course is right okay and then
you've got this guy over there right
inside okay now because you have now
combined those two log terms on the left
hand side you've got a single log on the
left and a single log on the right right
so these are these are equal to each
other you don't need to write the logs
anymore one or something and the same
base of something I can just write this
equals -2 are you happy with that
okay so you've used your log laws to
combine things but now that you have
this in exactly the sentence when you
see it equation like this right in this
case you would write the right-hand side
with the same base of the left-hand side
and having successfully done that you're
going to need the base of 3 anymore I
would just say x equals 2
makes sense so here I don't need the
multi-award one it is fundamental so now
what
you're going to add to exercise bringing
that looks moving things around
it's an equation so through the same
thing to both sides I was adding 2x to
both sides like so okay and now you
completely turn this question into a
quadratic question haven't you so you
can factorize this of course is and then
that gives you a pair of solution namely
okay now a did point in a rush you're
like sweet next question off I go okay
however I slightly lied to you I am
surprised and this light here I said I
said oh we've changed this question
completely into a quadratic question
yeah but no because this part looks like
a quadratic question but where the
questions begin was on one question and
that stuff hasn't gone away
right you have to account for this so
how did that effect has that effect this
think about this and this is always a
good question
there is implied in first line even
though it's not fatal
there is implied a domain restriction
right if I showed you this log base 2 of
X and I said can you graph this if I
asks you to grasp this then the domain
restriction is kind of at the forefront
of your mind because you know what the
future looks like do you not what is the
look like it's just got that gentle
curve you can see right so the domain
restriction is right there on the face
of what if the dimension momentarily if
X is Brandon 0 right and it's not
inclusive as the battery is never get
there because as an asymptote a vertical
asymptote so far so good now you have a
look it up here and you don't have
mobile web speaking have more ladies
cousins tomorrow into X right this guy
is just like one base 2 of X with one
exception
it's the
shifted two units to the left has it it
so if these won't be too of X then it
really may be cheap that is log base 2 X
plus 2 is that okay now do you notice
because it's now all in terms X plus 2
not X these depend you domain
restriction
yeah so therefore X is greater than not
deeper but negative 2 okay keep that in
mind there's restriction here X is
greater than negative 2
okay there's also structure here with it
however interesting with you right
you're adding these two things together
so that it matters what it is but you
have a dozen like the whole thing
doesn't exist if one of the pieces
explodes
okay so therefore even though this is
greater than negative 3 which is over
here like that right do you notice that
on this little portion here this graph
doesn't exist does that make sense
so therefore this guy doesn't exist
which means you can't add up when
there's like it's a fine thing it is
undefined to be okay so actually this
piece over here is worthless to me okay
even though this refines to this this is
what you need to get both of them that
make sense so I'm going to underline
that one to emphasize that the important
one okay is one more water which means
this one water main restriction and look
it's not like big 2x it went back to
minus 2x
what does that
[Music]
according to do hair is a means to be
making okay the domains usually get from
here is X is less than zero the question
is why dig back right when I told you
you've got a function like this and then
I said hey what about this what's the
relationship between these two and the
answer is you've done a flip a
reflection what direction have you
fitted
you got it horizontally right because X
is about horizontal values yes
so therefore this guy here looks like
log base 2 to X except except he's got
to this side and now he's just flipped
right over
to that time okay so here with my log
base 2 of X plus 2 grand
here's the other looks like myself to be
terrible but it's going to go that way
it's going to go in the other direction
right so now this is a bit of a
disastrous mess because I want to ask
the graphs if this doesn't look very
group but in order for this equation to
me anything then all three of these have
to exist - that makes sense
there's only one little section where
all three exist is to the left of here
and then I have to stop there you see
that obviously if I look to the right
you've got me to because none of this
one if I go any further than here you
get these two but not that one I want
all of them
ok this section here is the only one
where I get all of them so therefore the
real restriction that applies this whole
question is this whoops sorry
right negative 2 is the left are 3 and 0
is the white country so now when you
have a look at this you can see not all
of the solutions that we've found
through our quadratic meet these
conditions only one of the times nearly
this guy so the way I would say it is
but this restriction is in place
therefore X is negative 1
only as nearly 6 outside the domain and
they're typically more on English
exactly for one more the rest of
effective to my left is that just
finding out researching sister 3
operation yeah I almost certainly say 1
2 3 and also finally lenient and let
people have mark there because that use
of a lot more but I'm hoping you talk to
them
just evaluate this because all this
question here all this question was was
sold their shadows is yes however I'm
sort of pushing upon that because at
certain points you don't you don't want
to just be sort of brought back down to
just brute forcing others just Mercer to
try it okay you want to be able to think
about this before example I could have
said grass is amiss and then graphed it
and then followed over this question
right in which case you need to
understand all this stuff anyway
or I could have said give me the domain
restriction on this or give the dairy
researcher on it and that would have
been a different kind of question that
you can't just simply plug value do you
need on sale this so try every yes but I
still think this is a helpful thing to
having to her